me when I'm when I'm talking to all the
different cams I have a very easy time
getting a text back a callback a message
back from every Camp except for one camp
and that's the DeSantis Camp how much of
this because this is your world so for
me all I know is how to be a CEO and as
a CEO of a company if one of my guys you
reach out to he's probably asking me so
the pace he gets back to you it's really
my Pace right the speed of the leader
that determines the speed of the past
100 right so how much of this is he's
just got a bad marketing team and how
much of it is him just being slow to get
back because he thinks his strategy is
I'm above it all I don't need to be
there I don't need to experience this
I'm going to do whatever I want to do
and I'm still going to win yeah and and
that's a mistake to think that way so
let me just kind of tell you one phone
call to president Trump he's like I'm
all in I'm there let me know right he is
earning the front runner status status
right now there is zero entitlement on
behalf of Donald Trump I had dinner with
him a week and a half ago we have a very
good relationship I think the world of
him he's a great president
don't agree with him on all the stuff he
did especially with vouching the vaccine
whatever he was a great president I'm
100 behind him and I am really thrilled
with how he's trying to earn the
nomination doing events doing rallies
doing interviews Vivek ramaswami to his
great credit text message in five
minutes Charlie I'll be there
it is very difficult to get
communication from Governor DeSantis
team I completely agree I don't know if
that's the pace of the executive the CEO
I don't know if it's a culture around
there but I'm telling you right now he's
on Pace to finish third or fourth in
this primary Vivek ramaswamy is on Pace
to be the second vote getter in this
nomination that's wild
you would say like right now he's
there's no there's no like even if right
now DeSantis wakes up and goes guys
Everybody's In Charge out no team man
he's done it's someone fixable I'm not
saying it's done I'm not saying that but
he's trending the trajectory is really
poor for him it's he's coming across as
if he feels like he's entitled he's he's
engaging in a policy debate where the
Republican base does not want a policy
debate right now they want who is going
to go in with a spine and honestly the
balls to go into DC and fight against
this unit party regime it's it's a lot
more ethos and pathos than it is logos
so he's entering this like like it's a
Yale policy debate like oh high taxes
low taxes he's using like really weird
abstract academic terms that I can
resonate with which is we're going to
securitize the Border like yeah nobody
talks like that okay how about Donald
Trump says I'm gonna build a wall and
I'm going to deport the enemies like
that resonates but more than that Donald
Trump is an alpha beast and people want
that in this hyper feminine post-modern
culture we're living in and so they look
at him and yeah he's willing to go to
CNN with Caitlin Collins and just take
questions and like you're a liar and
you're a fraud and you're a fake and so
Trump's going to come to our event and
he's going to be wearing you know big
red tie and talk for an hour and a half
and you look at him and you have an
attachment to him because like that guy
is going to be able to go toe-to-toe
with Gigi ping right he's going to be
able to who whatever world leader you
want okay and so then there's there's
this attachment where he almost creates
this like mythological
type of
um archetype where young young people
all people see it and they say there
that guy has the status the attitude the
vibe and the energy Governor DeSantis is
like yeah I did great in Florida now
elect me as president
and people like no I actually I want
someone who can go into the UFC ring and
Dethrone the alpha and until you can go
into the arena and out Trump trump
you're gonna finish second third fourth
or fifth this is not a policy debate